okay I have no idea what just happened
but all I know is I pushed a video
public that was supposed to be for
everybody and people hated it I was like
what was so wrong about what I said like
I'm just like trying to save you guys
money and everyone's like sellout I hate
this guy and then I started reading the
comments and I started to like realize
that that video was somehow somehow
spammed out to you guys but being marked
as members only which is absolutely
hilarious uh but not the intent and also
if that was intentional that would be
disgusting guys so first of all
everyone's like like calling me a
hypocrite and stuff and like on the one
hand I totally get it but on the other
hand all the people that are like unsub
you would unsub over that one thing like
come on like I'm so sick and tired of
people being like like willing to just
forgo the last seven years of things for
like one little mishap like and this was
obviously a mistake in all that but
still come on guys so anyway my opinion
has not changed on the matter
there will be no members only content in
terms of like video content and stuff
like that that's that's silly if there's
a tutorial I want to cover it and I want
to share it with everybody and if you
want to support me in that endeavor
awesome the way that works is when I
upload a video the video is the
monetization status is not really
established for a video until 24 to 48
hours have gone by during that time
frame your video can be demonetised and
all the money you made in that first 24
to 48 hours which is usually where
you're gonna make the most money is lost
so what YouTube recommends is you upload
that video to be unlisted but of course
when you do that you know nobody gets
the video so with members what I do is I
let members watch that because it's like
well there's not a bunch of them and
then also they're paying so it's like
hey this is a cool perk I can give
because otherwise the video is just
sitting there like it's doing nothing
it's just a thing I can do so that's
what I do and everybody knows about that
but then after I published the video
publicly and I've been doing this for
like the last
I don't know probably hundred videos or
something and it's been fine but then
this morning for whatever reason I
posted it publicly it was still being
classified as for members only that was
not the intent and can you imagine if
that was possible how many people would
have use that like spamming videos out
and then people click in it's like it's
for members only like that would be lame
as hell like that is not even an option
you can't do that even if you wanted to
because some dirty people would really
want to do that ok but that's not me
that was not intentional that was a bug
that's not it's just not an option it
can't happen
so anyways turns out you guys don't
actually hate cloud versus local GPU
discussion you hate the members only but
yeah that was that was hilarious I'm
looking at I'm like what the heck is
going on
ok anyway I'm gonna try to republish
that video and yeah alright that's all
bye bye